مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عويده
[موسيقى]
نفاع بعد مباراه الهلال وناف باخور
الاوزبكي بدوري ابطال اسيا صار في
انتقادات كثير على نيمار وناس قالت انه هو
عبق وانه هو عالي على الفريق وفي ناس
انتقدت اداؤه بالملعب وفي ناس شافت انه
كان ي حق الطرد بسبب لقطته مع لاعب الفريق
الاوزبكي وكان في وجهات نظر كثير حول
موضوع نيمار ولكن هل فعلا نيمار عبا على
الهلال ولا هو قيمه مضافه للفريق بكل
صراحه وتعال نحكي فنيا وهذا الكلام قلناه
ورجعنا الفيديو اللي حكيناه اول ما انتقل
نيمار الى الهلال نيمار كلاعب اكيد
امكانياته هائله وهو من افضل لاعبي العالم
ومن افضل المواهب اللي طلعت باخر تقريبا
20 سنه ولكن بالنسبه للهلال الهلال كان
عنده سالم الدوسري اوريدي موجود وبقيمه
كبيره كجناح وعنده لاعبين وسط مميزين يعني
عنده سافتش وعنده نيفيس وعنده سال سلمان
الفرج وعنده غيره من اللاعبين المميزين في
منتصف الملعب وكنانه وغيرهم وبالتالي
الاضافه الفنيه اللي راح يقدمها نيمار
للهلال من البدايه ما كان متوقع انها تكون
كبيره انتبه هذا لا يعني انه نيمار لن
يقدم شيء مع الهلال لا نيمار اكيد مع مرور
المباريات المباره ورا مباراه رح يكون
اداؤه بشكل تصاعدي وراح يقدم وراح يدي
كثير منيح مع الهلال ولكن كقيمه فنيه كان
الهلال بحاجتها الهلال ما كان بحاجه نيمار
ولكن التعاقد مع نيمار كان لاسباب
تسويقيه لذلك مش لازم تتفاجا لما تشوف
اداء نيمار مش ذلك الاداء الخارق اللي كنت
تشوفه مع برشلونه وباول موسم مع بي اس جي
لانه متابع نيمار بيعرف انه باخر مواسم
نيمار مستواه نزل كثير عن فتره ما كان ب
برشلونه ولاسباب غير فنيه على فكره اسباب
نزول مستوى نيمار هي اسباب ذهنيه ورح نجي
لهي النقطه لاحقا ولكن فنيا الهلال لم يكن
بحاجه نيمار نعم وجود نيمار الان قد يعطي
اضافه قد يعطي شيء جديد للفريق 100% ولكن
كخيار فني داخل ارضيه الملعب كان في مراكز
بالنسبه للهلال كانت اولى انه يتم تعزيزها
متفقين على هي النقطه اعتقد انه كل جماهير
الهلال متفقه على هذا الموضوع ولكن فكره
انه نيمار يلعب بالهلال فكره قدوم نيمار
الى الهلال هي فكره جذابه ولا يمكن
مقاومتها ولا حتى معارضتها لان فكره تبدو
تسويقيا رائعه جدا وجماهيريا رائعه جدا
نيمار امام الفريق الاوزبكي كان واحد من
اسوا لاعبي الهلال هذا كلام اعتقد معظم
الناس متفقين عليه لمسات سيئه تمريرات
خاطئه عدم فاعليه قرارات غلط بالثلث
الامامي وبالتالي هي الامور كلياتها ادت
لانه نيمار يظهر بهذا المستوى بس مثل ما
حكينا نيمار رايح بمستوى تصاعدي وقد يتحسن
اداؤه لانه هي اول مباراه رسميه للاعب
البرازيلي مع الهلال على المرحل الاخر
تسويقيا الهلال طبعا دفع 99 مليون دولار
لحتى يستفيد تسويقيا من نيمار صفقه نيمار
واحده من الصفقات اللي لا تعتبر انها
رياضيه بالمقام الاول هي تعتبر صفقه
تسويقيه بالدرجه الاولى
والاخيره وبالتالي وجود نيمار مع الهلال
هو بحد ذاته عامل تسويقي مهم ولكن هون في
قلق صغير بينتد مني لما افكر بهذا الموضوع
انه نيمار بحال ادى بشكل سيء مع الهلال
فهذا احراج احراج للمدرب اللي هو اساسا
كما يقال ببوز المدفع يعني هو اللي راح
يتلقى كل الانتقادات لانه عم حط مثلا
لاعبين ممكن يكونوا احق من نيمار وقادرين
يادوا بده افضل من نيمار ومتعودين على
اللعب مع نادي الهلال من سنوات على دكه
البدلاء على بسبيل انه نيمار يلعب اساسي
وهذا امر قد يؤثر ايضا على اداء الهلال قد
يؤثر على نتائج الهلال في قادم المباريات
اذا نيمار ما تحسن بالدرجه الكاف وبالتالي
موضوع التسويق نعم مهم في عالم كره القدم
بس ما يكون على حساب الامور الرياضيه لانه
ساعتها ممكن يتحول لتسويق سلبي الناس تبطل
تحب تشوف الهلال تزعل لما تشوف نيمار
بالملعب لانه تعرف انه المستوى مش راح
يكون بالشكل اللازم الهلال ممكن يخسر ممكن
يتعثر لانه عم ليلعب بجناح لا بساند
دفاعيا ولا هو فعال هجوميا اذا قدم
المستوى اللي قدمه امام الفريق الاوزبكي
المتوقع انه يتحسن وبالتالي خلينا نقول
انه هي الفرضيه لحد الان بعيده والقفز
والاستنتاج انه نيمار عالي او نيمار عبا
على الهلال هذا امر مبكر جدا جدا جدا انه
نحكي فيه وان نحكم على نيمار بالوقت
الراهب المشكله اللي بعاني منها نيمار
واللي اهم من الامور الفنيه واهم من اداؤه
داخل ارضيه الملعب هو تصرفاته خارج ارضيه
الملعب عقليه نيمار عقليه كلنا بنعرف انه
هي يعني مش افضل شيء ومش من افضل اللاعبين
على صعيد الانضباط والسلوك خارج ارضيه
الملعب وهي سبب مشاكله كانت مع برشلونه
ومع باريس سان جيرمان والان بدات
تتضح يعني تفاصيل او امور عن مشكله جديده
لنيمار اسبانيا كشفتها صحيفه المركه ولكن
نحن ما رح نحكي فيها لحتى نتاكد من
الموضوع ويطلع شيء رسمي بس كان في تلميحات
من صديقه نيمار على الانستغرام نشرت اللي
هي حبيبته يعني او شريكته نشرت ستوري على
الانستغرام قالت فيها انا على راي بما
يحدث وما تتحدثون عنه ولكن انا مركز الان
على موضوع الحمل اللي هي حامل يمكن مش
عارف با شهر وبالتالي مركزه مع موضوع
بنتها اللي جاي على الطريق ومش مركزه مع ه
الامور وشكرت الناس اللي بعثت رسائل
وبالتالي نيمار التخوف الاكبر منه هو خارج
ارضيه الملعب هذا اللي ممكن ياثر على اداء
نيمار بالملعب وهذا اللي اثر على اداء
نيمار بالملعب وهذا اللي خلى نيمار ما
يكون واحد من افضل لاعبي العالم بفتره من
الفترات لانه كان ممكن نيمار يجيب الكره
الذهبيه ويجيب كاس العالم ويجيب كثير
بطولات ولكن عقليته هي اللي خلته يوصل
لمرحله انه ما يكون ضمن مصاف افضل لاعبي
العالم لذلك التخوف من نيمار خارج ارضيه
الملعب نيمار لحد الان ما بدنا نظلمه فنيا
ولكن يجب عليه انه يغير سلوكه يغير تعاطيه
مع الحياه يهدى شوي ويكون مركز اكثر بكره
القدم ويطلع من عقليه بعض اللاعبين
البرازيليين او كثار من اللاعيب
البرازيليين اللي دمروا مسيرتهم بسبب
الامور اللي كانت تصير معهم خارج عضيه
الملعب هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعدض
الصاف حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا
بالف
خير